okay so I want to spend basically the
rest of the time we have here discussing
the real underlying issue doll this
which is very much related to everything
I do on the show about free speech and
the role of government all this stuff so
you mentioned Al Gore before and you
know what one of my things with Al Gore
is that you know he's I saw the movie An
Inconvenient Truth I really liked it at
that when did that come out about 2006
2006 okay I really really liked it at
the time I thought it we woke up some
things in me that maybe I hadn't thought
of before
fast fast forward to what about three
years ago Al Gore decided to sell
Current TV to the government of Qatar so
they could put Al Jazeera on here the
government car does tons of stuff with
fossil fuels so and he basically created
the producers he created a failed
Network and and profited on it for 500
million dollars I mean did the producers
he used he leveraged the first one to
point this out I've been saying it for a
while but he's basically max B I'll
stock like he created the pretty he
created a failed Network and then
ultimately he walked away with the ton
of money and the reason he was able to
create the network was cuz he was the
vice president had all the connections
and telecoms and all that stuff it's not
easy to get on cable channels and all
that but basically created a shitty
product that he walked away with a ton
of money and at the same time he took a
massive check from the government of
Qatar who does a ton obviously with
fossil fuels that he's always railing
against so I'm putting that out there
that I have no I suspect something's not
quite right with what this guy is doing
in the scheme of this thing but can you
lay out a perhaps more enlightened case
than that he's just doing the producers
cuz I sense that you don't care about
what well that so basically the the
federal government right now it sounds
like is starting to attack think tanks
right but they're attacking think tanks
that do the very work that you do now I
would argue that because I believe in
free speech that a think tank should be
allowed to think and I thought my
governmental control over thought even
if I completely disagreed with whatever
the premise of the think tank was going
but this is happening right now so first
up I guess is that directly related to
Al Gore somehow because he's not part of
the government
right but he is a figurehead I mean he I
don't even know what the legality of
this bit but when they announced this so
I guess we should get a little bit more
context ok so what's happened is over
the years what I call the climate
catastrophe and I just want to quickly
we haven't talked much about the climate
issue specifically just just in terms of
my view and other people's view there's
not this idea of climate believers and
climate deniers it's a really dumb kind
of alternative but there are different
assessments of the magnitude of the
warming influence of co2 so we put X
amount of co2 in the atmosphere so let's
say 130 parts per million their point a
1/3 percent since the beginning of the
Industrial Revolution and the question
is how much does that affect climate in
terms of primarily warming and then
anything that comes from warming and
then how much can it be anticipated to
effect in the future as we put another
point oh one percent another 0.01
percent another point one percent and so
basically and we could go into the
details but we don't have time some
people think that that's a very mild and
manageable warming mm-hmm and they point
to things like the amount of co2 in the
atmosphere in terms of the geology of
the globe is that almost record lows
temperatures are at almost record lows
so in terms of the history of the planet
when we had 20 times more co2 it was a
very fertile time co2 is plant food so
what they argue is that co2 and I argue
is it has a warming effect but it's what
it's called the decelerating or
logarithmic effect now that's actually
not controversial but then the other
side says well even though it's a
decelerating effect in the lab and the
atmosphere there are these other
dynamics that make it into this X
accelerating or a very dramatic thing
and that's why we can expect runaway
warm wave caused a real quick so the
decelerating meaning that at some point
even though you're putting this stuff
out it eventually starts sort of
estimating itself it's just like a
function like diminishing returns I mean
you think about like when you press the
pedal on your gas right so you at a
certain point every little push it goes
faster to like 55 and after they go slow
right otherwise you just take off like a
rocket right and could go forever yeah
so it's it's it's the same kind of thing
every molecule of co2 warms less than
less so this is an
controversial scientific fact which by
the way is part of why you need to learn
a little bit about the science you just
have to ask people the key thing is
what's demonstrated and what's
speculated so this phenomenon of co2 is
demonstrated but again there's this
other set of theories which I think are
very speculative certainly not proven
but have to do with catastrophic warming
but other people are allowed to have
those theories I don't want to suppress
the theories I think upon examination
they're very dubious and whatever they
are you have to look at them in the
context of the benefits of fossil fuels
so you always have to look at the big
picture no matter what but basically
what I call the K so I'm calling them
the catastrophe so it's not that's why I
call them the catastrophe so it's not a
non-believer I just believe in mild ok
so that that's just the distinction so
basically what the catastrophes have had
is what they consider failure now I
consider them enormously successful on
their own terms because I think they've
been doctrine ated you know the whole
world and had in past a lot of bad
policies but on their terms they have
not shut down the fossil fuel industry I
mean they want to shut down 80 percent
of it in the next 30 years and next 35
years they're not accomplishing that
they tried to pass cap-and-trade so what
they've done over the past several years
their basic premise is well the reason
we haven't done this people are idiots
and there must be some villain who's
causing this the resource who's the
villain Big Oil who's allegedly forcing
us to buy oil when in fact we basically
ask them to produce right so but so what
they did they have this thing called the
divestment movement which is basically
sell all of your oil stock and that'll
demonize them and everyone all hate them
and then they'll vote against it so that
hasn't work so well so far so now what
they have is is the government actually
prosecuting I would argue persecuting
the company so different attorneys
general so you know each state has an
attorney general and what they're doing
they're going after the biggest and
allegedly baddest Exxon Mobil and the
Attorney General's are saying basically
Exxon you over the years have not
expressed what we believe are the proper
climate catastrophes views and in fact
you have funded people who don't have
those views so if you just said that you
think oh well you're allowed to do that
right this is America you're free but
what they've done is they've called it
fraud but they said you've defrauded but
for many reasons it's not fraud and the
basic thing is for it to be fraud you
have to misread
and specific facts fraud does not expect
expressing a wrong opinion or even a
wrong opinion that serves you companies
do that all the time it's
misrepresenting specific facts that you
have specific access to right now
attention really well but it but it's a
specific thing like you have to
misrepresent so let's say Exxon selling
a kind of a certain kind of gasoline
then they misrepresent the contents of
that that's fraud but they didn't
misrepresent the fact that gasoline
emits co2 when you burn it everybody
knows that and the experts on that were
mostly government scientists Oh Exxon
didn't you have an ability to defraud it
had an ability to express opinions and
to fund people or be affiliated with
people express different opinions so
what happened then is the government
subpoenaed X on different people
subpoenaed X on but they also started
going after think tanks that they
suspected might be connected with Exxon
and several Wednesday's ago they came
after me or at least I was named in a
subpoena which means the government has
any right at wants to records of any
emails between anyone at my company and
anyone at Exxon so that in my views is a
complete violation of my rights and in
might case it's interesting because I
don't run a non-profit I don't run a
company that accepts donations a
for-profit company sell books they sell
lectures right so there's no
plausibility that Exxon is sort of
paying me to do something and they went
after me so why'd they go after me
because I have a prominent book called
the moral case for fossil fuels so what
they're saying to me is and what they're
saying to me is Alex because you
expressed an opinion we disagree with we
are going to invade your life right and
people are afraid of that so how are
they actually coming out like what are
they trying to do to you as a for-profit
business well I get what they can try to
do with with Exxon right they can
ultimately legislate things that would
allow Exxon to not do business the way
it seems they're not legislating there
prosecutor or prosecuting people in jail
right okay so okay so I understand that
but what can they do to you as the
Competitive Enterprise Institute at
least for a while they were going after
that organization so they're going after
that organization as a party to it
because if Exxon is committing fraud
then the people who help it can be
considered a party to that fraud but you
see that the core issue I just think my
case brings out that the core issue is
expressing an opinion that the
government disagrees with so
I mean it just goes against just you
know fundamental principle of progress
is free speech because we can't make
progress without having the freedom to
discuss ideas and debate ideas and have
intellectual clarity and so for this to
happen is is really horrible and I think
I'm in a position where because I was I
was only named on the subpoena I wasn't
subpoenaed now I could be in the future
but right now I'm I have a lot of
latitude to speak out I have a hundred
percent ownership of my company I don't
have shareholders I don't have donors so
I'm not accountable to anybody so I have
an ability to be very vocal about this
issue now and I'm taking advantage of it
hopefully to preempt them from doing
something more in the future I saw they
did some attack recently and I wasn't
named in it I don't know if that was a
coincidence or not right I defend I just
want to make clear I defend exons right
to express its opinion I actually think
it's been wet it's given way more money
to climb at catastrophists than it has
to
I would say climate thinkers which I
would call myself I think in general
they've been way too sympathetic they
just came out in favor of a tax on co2
they've been promoting that's I think
their policies are wrong in the wrong
direction but they can say anything they
want and certainly they think they've
given too much away I know out of guilt
sort of or whatever the word private
anti-humanist 100 I've sort of guilted
them into doing more than you would
argue they should have done because you
guys none right I mean I should have
done none but but particularly given the
balance of funding already I mean you're
talking orders of magnitude different
amounts of funding for the
catastrophists mm-hmm versus any kind of
advocate of fossil fuels but they gave
100 million dollars to Stanford's
climate program a hundred million
dollars for every calculation I've seen
that's way more they've given to anyone
else that this you know these think
tanks these nonprofits I mean I really
admire a lot of them I met a lot of the
people I think they're really sincere
and they have a hell of a time getting
funding from any of these these
companies I think the company should
give them I don't need money I have a
different kind of business but I think
they should be giving a lot more money
to fund opposition research and that's a
fundamental thing in a free society and
the one key function of industry is to
if the industry is being attacked it
should fund opposition right I mean it's
it's even like now says if you even take
the debate
go industry tobacco should fund research
what it shouldn't do is misrepresent and
lie about the research or fund fraud but
you know if somebody let's say somebody
was exaggerated I don't know anything
about tobacco and I never spoke but like
let's say somebody was exaggerating by a
factor of four the damages of tobacco
and you wanted to do research that would
be legitimate so what my point is in a
free society you should be able to talk
about anything you want the idea this
isn't a marginal case this is a
completely normal thing for people to be
able to talk about and it's really scary
that that that that people think is okay
this is on the Democratic proposed
platform all Hillary Clinton has to do
is sign and this is part of their
platform that and and what kind of
stupid platform is it to tell the
executive branch to go out that's
shouldn't the platform supposed to be
legislative so it's just bizarre but
they're telling the executive branch to
go after specific companies that's their
platform yeah that's a whole other topic
what's going on with politics I get
regressive it's it's the regressive that
Wow I almost got through it sure without
saying progressives there you go but so
that I guess what's happening here is
that there's something sort of a bigger
cultural thing here so you we're talking
about this in through the lens of fossil
fuels and all that stuff well there's
just a sort of bigger thing which is
what I've really made this show about
which is just about free speech and
that's why I keep talking about it so
much because I think people don't
realize again regardless of what you
think about climate change in fossil
fuels and everything else that you've
said here but that the real linchpin
here is the free speech stuff and I keep
saying that I don't fear it the
government coming lately I fear that
we're taking away from ourselves but
you're laying out a pretty good case on
the government side so that's even more
along related I mean I imagine you're
talking about like these these what are
they comfort zones on safe spaces and
the trigger warning since I was and
self-censorship that we're doing
relentless I mean I graduated Duke in
2002 yeah and it was I mean it was bad
then but it wasn't I mean I'm actually
almost got kicked out of Duke for
yelling at a guest environmentalist
speaker but in general there weren't
even those terms said that this idea of
thought control the I think there's a
relationship even even sort of private
thought control that's not directly Co
but where you basically make everybody
afraid to say anything about any
controversial topic my guess is that
makes people very comfortable with
government not control that's
interesting that's interesting all right
so we got to wrap up but what would be
give me you're like one minute sort of
if you wanted people that have heard
this and that have said all right I
never bought into any of this stuff but
I you know I like some of this what this
guy has said what's the one minute push
that you can give them to explore this a
little bit more beyond buy my book which
I'm going to talk about when I say
goodbye yes it's an issue I usually
bring up more so I want I'll say this
whenever we look at any issue in life
we're implicitly or explicitly saying
this is good because I define good this
way we always have an implicit
definition of good whether we're talking
about climate or fossil fuels or free
speech or whatever and so my what I call
my standard of value is always I want to
maximize human flourishing and I think
in our culture today the standard of
value were taught particularly with
environmental issues is we want to
minimize human impact on the planet so I
want people to think whenever they run
into these issues ask ask themselves is
this thinker on the premise of maximum
human flourishing or are they on the
premise of minimum human impact and I
think when you look at things whether
it's organic food or GMO or climate
you'll see a lot of that minimum impact
is the ideal and I think that completely
contradicts maximizing human wellbeing
so if you want to maximize flourishing
you want to maximize you want to
minimize negative impacts but you want
to maximize positive impacts hitting is
a great filter to look at life through
yeah that's a perfect closing but I
should mention that you said to me right
before we started that one of my former
guests Michael Mann who's a climate
scientist I think at Penn State Penn
State am i right yeah that he he's
blocked you on Twitter which I guess
goes to a little bit of just how
contentious this whole thing is because
you are asked to you a Muskies Blatty to
I mean but we have what was interesting
about Michael Mann I'd say when when
watch Michael Mann speaker I encourage
anyone to watch any of his eyes lecture
7c got interview but I've seen his
lectures look at the precision or non
precision about the issue of what is
demonstrated versus what is speculated
what they tend to do is they'll say
something trivial like co2 warms
whichever and agrees with and they'll
jump into therefore it's catastrophic so
just look at is Michael Mann really
respecting your mind is he really
explaining things with the degree of
precision that would be necessary for
you to really understand the topic I'm
not asking you to take a position I'm
just think people should think about
that and one indication is how they deal
with debate now people can I don't block
people other people they can have their
policy but Michael Mann wrote a post
that said Alex Epstein is the Koch
brothers attack dog which wouldn't be a
negative thing in my view but it was the
Czar I mean it was not true I mean
nobody was funding me at all and he just
made it up he just completely made it up
the idea what he didn't engage my
argument and then I said something to
the effect of this is a lie what is your
evidence and then he blocked yeah so
it's it's what you see there is that
when people so there are two types of I
think having the moral high-ground one
is when you have a real confidence and
that's when you're willing to explain
your views to people and the other is
where you have a certain societal status
where it's not really earned but it's
considerate you you dominate the
politically correct version you have the
political correctness at this point in
time in society and when people have
that kind of pseudo moral authority they
do all sorts of irrational things so
when somebody acts like they have the
moral high ground I think seeing if
they're really a debater or whether they
just want to dictate to you that's or
ignore you that's a really good test I
think it's a good you know one of the
reasons why people really value this
show is you know you're not an
unconfident guille though you know
you're interviewing people but it's you
know there's a certain confidence in
being willing to discuss things with
anyone and there's a certain it's very
revelatory when people are not willing
to assess things in their number one
talking point is there's nothing to
discuss I always find it funny it's that
I I never felt I've never in my life
felt the need to be right all the time
and everyone I feel in the public space
always wants to prove how right they are
so I'm completely fine having this
conversation and maybe I would look back
now on my interview with Michael Mann
and sort of look at
through a bit of a lens of what you've
just said there maybe if I have him on
again what I would push him on some of
those things all right well that's the
conversation I want to happen that's why
we did it so you guys can get Alex's
book it's the moral case for fossil
fuels and check out industrial progress
calm the link for the book is right down
below thanks for watching and we'll do
it again next week
you